thanks for coming sorry that I'm a
little bit late
so this tutorial is about experimental
machine learning using hollow piece and
PI torch in Jupiter environments and
just briefly about myself I'm doing my
PhD at USC and I work on extracting
semantics from unstructured data as like
images text and try to gain insights so
everyone here this is how experimental
machine learning with all of yous PI
torch in Jupiter lab or GPR notebook so
today's goal is to make your data
exploration and model building process
more interactive and exploratory the
main goals will be to use Jupiter
environment and this visualization
library called hollow views and its
ecosystem and pi torch to train our
model and then along the way we will
have to kind of touch use other
libraries like pandas geo pandas and
numpy so I will I will be assuming that
you are familiar with some kind of
machine learning pipelines as well as
some tools like pi torch and tensor flow
I won't be able to do all the justice to
those amazing libraries but I'll just
kind of walk you through the entire
workflow of how I usually would do data
exploration and model building as well
as evaluating the train models so the
specific application is multi class
image segmentation with interactive
visualization and experimental model
building so the specific problem we're
gonna look at is detecting different
types of roads from the satellite images
so the image you're looking at right now
is a region in student called Curtin
it's actually the capital of Sweden and
I was given this data
said with a bunch of satellite images as
well as some of the roads say road mask
label by experts so we see that there is
purple line that indicates motorways
like big highways or any ways that cars
can usually drive on and our yellow
lines are residential roads where the
people it's near the people's houses and
the blue lines are unpaved roads and so
the problem will be given all this
training data that we can use how can we
detect the roads that are not segmented
by experts so is it a motorway
residential way is it a pave way so we
would like to be able to build a model
that can do this work for us another
similar data in the same direction I
also had this Las Vegas which were quite
different from Khartoum in that a lot of
these roads are actually highways and
rather the landscape of the picture that
we get from these satellite images are
quite different so how can we build a
model that generalizes these different
satellite images is also another
question that we can look at so I chose
this topic of Road segmentation because
it's very applicable to other similar
vision tasks so here we're seeing that
the first image the left image is the
one of the retinal image in our eyes so
given this image we would like to just
extract out these retinal blood cells I
find it kind of interesting that these
these are kind of similar to finding
roads right in the satellite images and
also a little bit different case is to
extract different parts of your brain
based on this medical image
sorry and another a little bit different
case is detecting text from historical
maps so the input images are historical
maps and we will like to it's very hard
for to hire humans to extract out these
texts so we would like to extract out
this with some automatic algorithm so
here we have a bunch of image tiles from
the historical maps and some people some
nice people label these text regions and
also we can use it for more real-life
modern images on the right where we
would like to just extract out this text
images so today's agenda would be to
first introduce you to all of you see of
use and their ecosystem and then we
would like to start using it on our own
data set and then use param which is
another library in the hall of use
ecosystem to build our easily
configurable near Network model and then
we're gonna kind of bring back the whole
of use to be able to visualize the
training process as well as the Train
models performance on our test images so
so why all of you is um so the general
machine learning workflow is you first
ask some kind of question and then we go
out and get our data and then once we
have this data we kind of try to
understand what these data are about and
then build a model that solves our
problem and then we would like to
communicate the results so what does our
model actually predicting and at each
step of this workflow we need to be able
to visualize what we're doing both the
data and then the model and Halloweens
is um and I usually think a lot of
people these days start explorative
stage
their model building using Jupiter
environment so how obvious is a nice way
to bring this visualization power inside
your Jupiter environment while you're
exploring and building your data so
sometimes you have to use because
visualization itself can be become an
entire work like a side project to do
it's hard to this entangle your model
building and data exploration or
visualization but halt of use makes it
kind of easy to combine those two
workflows so Jupiter and hall of use and
PI torch and you can actually extend it
to tensor board so it makes this
workflow very easy so for this tutorial
I would like to go through this workflow
with you and then see what we can do so
the first question would be as the
images showed to segment out the roads
from satellite images so it's a
supervised machine learning question
meaning you we need both the input the
image data as well as some labels of
which pixels in those images are roads
or the type of roads so if each is
concerned if you're just concerned about
Road versus non Road it would be a
binary classification but we actually
want to go one step further and then do
multi-class classification so we would
like to distinguish if it's highway
residential footway or narrow road so
here are some of the data that we're
going to look at and you can see that
sometimes it's actually really difficult
because there are the shades from the
trees and other buildings and just a raw
pixel value in your image doesn't
necessarily tell you whether it's a road
or not so this is one snippet of the
visualization that we can make using all
of use so we can compare these two
examples
the image and on top of it has the mask
and then on the left you can actually
download external data from
OpenStreetMap or other database online
by using the geo reference in your
original image so here you're looking at
an interactive GUI where you can see
your data on the left and depending on
the bounding box of your region of your
image or automatically fetching the data
from the OSM and then visualizing it on
the right so we can use this tool to
explore our data and here we're actually
seeing the input data from this
challenge called space net where most of
the satellite image and the masks are
coming from and one good thing about it
is that you can actually hover over
these images and then see the labels
interactively which is very I find it
almost not possible using like my pot
leap even though I really think it's a
great library there are some interactive
I think all of us adds that
interactivity and we're gonna so this is
kind of in the middle of the training
when we use the input data of more
common type we see the mask the ground
truth math on the left and then on the
right we see the prediction in the
middle of the training so it's trying to
kind of predict that it's our CAD and
there's the background but we see that
some of these are actually not fully
trained so in the middle of the training
we can actually inspect what the model
is learning and how well it's performing
and then at the end we can give some
test data and then interactively as we
vary it's like a queer in your Jupiter
environment where you can use the
drop-down box or a slider in York way to
input your test data and then run your
model in the backend automatically and
then see the result on top of your test
image so first the first step is to
introduce Harlow views libraries so it's
a very I think I first started to using
it this summer for like a large
geospatial data visualization and I
found it really useful and also very
applicable to machine learning tasks so
but unfortunately will be touching only
the tip of the iceberg but they have
great resource online like their
tutorials talks inside PI and their user
guide and examples are really great so
the key principle behind Holub use is
that it's a ticket
declarative visualization tool not
imperative which means you kind of tell
what you want and then it'll give you
the visual representation instead of the
steps that you have to take and it's
also data centered not plus centered and
we'll see more about what that means and
it's about annotating your data directly
with semantics of what your data means
for example if I just give you an umpire
array you if there's no content about
this right what does this value mean
what does when I see it as a PLT that I
am sure what am I seeing right so but
holo views kind of helps you annotate oh
x axis means latitude y axis means
longitude
the value you're looking at is actually
temperature so that helps you to add
those annotations into the data set
that's that's just about the numbers
that's hold that's more like a storage
so it's a good way to annotate your data
and it's also a great way to separate
your data content from visual
representation and that way you can
combine different data elements and then
build more complex visual representation
just briefly about what it means to be
data centered it means that so I'll just
read verbatim from I went from the
common of one of the core developers he
says personally I don't want a grammar
of graphics I want a grammar of data
where the data with data happens to have
a graphical representation I don't want
to spend ages piecing together a fancy
plot I want to spend just a little time
entertaining my data to declare what it
means and then doe matter how I slice
and dice my data it'll show up in a
meaningful way that way I can explore it
to easily understand it which is the
point of hollow views so so the core
part of that parts that we're gonna
explore is its interactivity and start
with the data not the coding and avoid
entangling your data code and
visualization and then we're gonna do
all of this in Jupiter environment so
maybe we'll come back to this later so I
think we can now go back go to the
github repo I don't know if everyone has
the access to the repo so it's it's
github that come slash Co Co AAA
in PI data la 2019 if I can connect to
Wi-Fi give me one sec
yeah Co Co aaaa it's also in the
[Music]
schedule de piedra schedule in my
abstract it's github.com Co Co AAA slash
capital P small Y capital ta ta ta / la
/ - LA - 2019 yeah sorry so there are
two main building blocks in hollow views
the first one is container or the first
one is elements type element and the
other one is type containers which are
the composites of elements and some of
these examples are taken from all of us
- toriel's so first elements the first
element we're gonna look at is hollow
views points so hv means hall of use and
so here the way we use we make this
hollow these objects are you passing
your data to the hollow views
constructors so here we first define
points by a set of points and then we do
hollow views points and then we give our
data points
sorry
so we just go through all the imports
oh so you can actually open up the
binder so if you go to the readme of the
repo there's a small binder button that
you can just click and it'll spawn up
the binder environment where you don't
have to actually install the libraries
yourself and then you can just follow
along the notebooks it may take some
time to start it up oh no no so if you
go to the readme if you just click on
the repo there's a rip me and then
there's a small button that says launch
binder and if you click on it it'll
start on your environment it'll show you
that it's building and after some time
it'll put you in the environment where
you can just test on or try the
notebooks
it'll also download some data sorry so
this is the repo and then here you can
click on the launch binder button and if
you click on it it'll build a new
environment so first we need to import
all the necessary libraries so here I'm
importing some basic ones including holo
views here so we do import holo views as
HV and then some options that we're
gonna use for stylizing our
visualizations and then we because we're
running in notebook
we need HV that notebook extension we're
gonna use Phuket but it also use it you
can also use either MATLAB or plotly and
other extensions
and in the bottom were setting some
default visualization of options so for
here I'm just using that for RGB type
data I'm gonna use certain default
settings as well as images points and
paths and tiles so finally elements so
the way we use these constructors are we
we pass in our data object to our
element type and then we use dimension
annotations so there are most main two
main dimensions which is called key
dimensions Kay themes and value
dimensions readings and so key
dimensions are your kind of independent
variables and readings you can sort of
think of it as these dependent variables
that you want to specify so here back
into our points we can say that the
points that we're gonna draw are these
on the x-axis it's point one to point
two
da-da-da-da-dah a hundred points and
then at for each of these points we're
gonna define a function that computes
the sine of that x value and then give
it to HV that points and here we see
that we get this little a bunch of
points here and we actually are able to
hover over these plots and then see the
values and if you do H that this hollow
views object that dimensions we actually
get
all dimensions here x and y are the
default dimensions another hollow views
element is all of these curves which
represents a set of sample pairs XY that
are assumed to have a deterministic
relation it's basically think of X
sample from this 1 dimensional space and
Y as some function of your input X and
then plot it as a curve so here we give
the same points and then we use a curve
as the different element type and in
this case instead of the previous points
we get the curves so a simple exercise
we can do is let's make a curve
representing a function f that is the
sigmoid of your input X so sigmoid is
one of the activation functions in
neural network and it's defined as 1
over 1 plus e to the negative x and you
can use any X as your domain and let's
try this
wisdom
so first we need to give the range of X
X X values they won't be want to show
and the y values would be this sigmoid X
so in this case I first define my
sigmoid function 1 over 1 plus numpy
that X to negative X and my ex will X's
will be just from negative 10 to 10 and
now simple 100 points and my Y's will be
the sigmoid of that function and if I
draw the curve it shows me this curve of
sigmoid from negative 10 to 10
that's your X and your Y and another
element is all of this scatter which
Express dependent relationship between
two variables so in this case unlike the
previous points X is understood as
independent variable Y as a dependent
variable so even though we see the same
plot they have different meanings
maybe this is
so there are two different types of
annotation tools that simple annotation
tools that you can use which is the H
line which means hole a horizontal line
and vertical line feel line so here we
see that we define some the some of
these new objects with y-value at 0 1
and 0.5 so these are the horizontal
lines at these Y points and I can change
the options by using this star opt and
then give some styles and all of these
are supporting the shift tab so it gives
you the key words that you can use and
in this case I'm using color and line -
and line width and by combining with the
sigmoid visualization I now get some
more annotations and by using this
overlaying
operation I can keep adding new elements
on top of my previous hello use objects
so I added a vertical line here and I
can kind of change the other settings
like the width and the padding padding
means the padding of your visual visual
representation so another quick exercise
that we can do is in the data folder
there's a CSV file called ice-cream
which shows 1950s ice cream consumption
versus temperature income and price
there are only 30 points but I found it
quite interesting so we can first read
our the CSV using pandas and then try to
explore the data set using some of the
tools that we we've we covered so here's
the
starting point so import pandas as PD
and then we read the data using PD read
CSV and then we see that cons means we
it has four columns name the cons income
price temperature and cons means
consumption and income and price and
temperature so we can use holo use curve
or points and then see how these two
different variables are related so
here's my version of what I tried so I
passed in the data which is the pandas
object here with four columns and using
the key themes which is adding your
annotation I'm saying when I make this
curve using HV curb I want to use
temperature and con's those two columns
as my key dimensions to my curve so it's
going to use temp in your on your x-axis
and cons as in your y-axis and then show
the plot so on your x-axis you see the
temperature on your y-axis you see the
consumption and it is that issues that
there is not real any pattern into this
it seems so people like ice cream
regardless of temperature but if you
want to actually show that oh now I
actually want to see the income as well
what we can do is in our opt we can just
pass in the name of your column as your
size of your scatter points and then we
see that these are the sizes are now
normalized to your income values I had
to use the normalization because incomes
are much bigger than these other values
so they kind of appear all too big if I
don't make them in the scale
zero and one in this case and then times
10 and then the color specifies the
black of your scatter points moving on
to Hall obvious image these are more
what you expect as like PLT I am show so
I'm here just showing this image so I'm
just plotting some x and y grid and
these color values are showing this sine
X plus y and you can specify different
bounds of your image the first one I'm
showing negative 1 negative 2 to 5 on
the second one I'm using just 0 and 3
what's more interesting to see is our
actual data so in the data samples
there's a some sample images that we're
gonna use one of them is just real life
image so we need to so ski and our image
is just another library that helps us
read those images and regularly you
would just call plot I am show but in
our case we can use hollow vias image
and how love use image is actually just
for 2d data so I had to just grab one
one channel the first channel and how
love use RGB is the one that we would
actually use to import 3 channel RGB
data and just a simple example with
generate generated synthetic data will
be that here I define my domain of x and
y using mesh grid it just kind of
defines your coordinate space and RGB
are the actual values and by passing in
these RGB as a stack array it gives up
this RGB images and these are actually
like all Interactive's
can move along and then see the values
and an explorer and if we actually pass
in now the actual image then we see the
RGB the full RGB instead of the just a
red image so I think because of the time
we can sort of move along skip this
exercise and there are two there another
building block of hall of use containers
which combines different elements and
then build all this more complex hollow
use object so the first operation that
we can use is this star which is kind of
like multiply but so we multiply two
hollow use elements meaning we put them
on top of each other and layout means
you put them on side by side so we use
plus sign for this and there is another
type of container called hollow Maps
which is useful for defining in
different parameter spaces what I mean
by different parameter spaces is if I
have a function that takes in two
parameters here sign already takes phase
and frequency so these are two different
parameters I want I want to be able to
show multiple images while varying these
values so what I can do is I first
define the function that takes in two
arguments and then build a Python
dictionary that generates own images by
giving different values to this
frequency and phases and if I do that
and then pass into this HV hollow maps
and specify what are my two
parameters in this case the name of your
arguments phase and frequency then it
actually gives you this kind of slider
that that helps that makes your values
change so this phase comes from these
values that you pass in as your face
values and frequency comes from the
values that you pass in in in your
dictionary so we see that these values
as you change these values this new H
all of your image objects are being
shown so one this is nice but one
drawback is that you kind of have to
specify and build all these images
before you explore but what we actually
put then if your images are actually too
big or your visualization becomes too
complex this is a problem what we would
rather want is just have these all of us
image or ha-lo these objects built when
we change the values using this slider
and what enables us to do that is how
obvious dynamic map and let's move on to
how the views dynamic map and you can go
to the 1 0 1 B I love you steam map
gaussians and we're going to quickly see
how we can use it to build some Gaussian
distribution visualization so this is
the notebook new different notebook
so in this case I first need to define
what I want to draw so I'm saying that
my X's are this linear linearly spaced
values between negative 5 & 5 and I want
100 points and my Y's are the Gaussian
values just 0 mean standard deviation 1
and I'm going to plot the curve and add
some annotations as we seen before and
I'm going to overlay these elements
using the star operator and the result
will be this so that's one element and
just briefly we can actually extend it
to three dimension which is
sorry for the sighs but I think if you
actually use plotly library here it
gives you the interactivity much better
maybe I can show you in mine so if you
actually install plotly I don't think
it's installed in the binder at this
moment but if you do like people install
plotly in your environment and then
you'll be able to see a 3d plot and you
can actually change the camera angles
and then see how it actually works
better so once we define this 3d Koshien
using this draw Gaussian 3d and we pass
into the dynamic map here then and then
specify our key dimensions as before in
this case those are the arguments that
defined here so mu mean in X dimension
mean in Y dimension Sigma in X and Y and
then X Y is just a cross product we will
not play with it at this moment and then
you see that you have this knobs where
you can change these values again if you
use our partly it should be able to move
around these Gaussian distributions and
then show without interactivity there
so I think now we can move on to more of
the PI torch part of it so in so PI
torch how's everyone doing
sorry for the technical which is I is
this the case for most of the people
who's able to launch the binder
are we ready to just move on to pipe
torch part of it yes okay I'll try to
fix everything after tutorial and you
can go back and and try those again so
the way PI torch the way I think of PI
torch workflow is like this so we have
we first need to say how we're gonna
input our data and we need to define our
loss function and of course they find
our model and then the optimizers will
basically have a linked to the
parameters inside your model so for
example your model can have some
convolution layers and the convolution
layer has weights and biases in pi torch
and these are usually and then that
parameter type data and they are tensors
and they are trainable how many people
are familiar with tensor instance of
pipe pipe torch great
okay and parameter is built on top of
tensor it adds the functionality of
tracking this Auto differentiation which
means when you do computations on your
tensor it builds it keeps track of the
computations that you're doing on top of
it so that when you do gradient descent
it knows what to do automatically
without you specifying what need to be
top what needs to be done to compute the
gradient so once we have this model
optimizer lost function and data loader
you do you need to do this mini-batch
gradient descent so this is one
iteration of mini-batch so data loader
gives you x and y and then we need to
send this data to the correct device
often times GPU or sometimes CPU and
that that's what this two operation of
the PI torch tensor is doing and when we
do model and then this call this
function defined as under under call in
your model it will do the forward pass
for computation on your input X and then
it'll give you the output prediction of
your model and then we use our loss
function that we're going to define to
compute some kind of loss between your
prediction and target line so at this
point your loss this loss on this loss
is also a tensor that has been computed
using your input and the target Y and
then the we need to make sure before we
do any back properly prop that your
parameters gradients are zero because
usually because we don't want to
accumulate gradients on
that's the desired behavior so we call
optimizer that zero grad which makes all
your parameters attribute called cred
and it sets it to zero and when you do
loss that back backwards it calls the
auto differentiation on all the
parameters that you are training and
then it puts the gradient of your loss
with respect to each parameter into the
parameters grad attribute and then when
you do optimizer step that's when you
actually use the learning rate and some
other optimizer specific operations to
update your parameter value so here P is
a parameter of your model and then it
uses the gradient that's been
accumulated from your back prop and
learning rate to update its value so we
can go back to the Jupiter notebook so
the first step is to input your data set
and just need to run this for the
imports and here were importing the PI
search library standard imports like
torch torch that n n which has an N n
function optimizer optim and here torch
that util that data has the data set and
data loader which we will use to build
our own custom data sets and data
loaders
and so this is one example of the PI
torch dataset and here so data set needs
to have two attributes the first one is
this under-under length and another one
is this get item so what it is for is
when you do length of an array in python
like le n of your array that's when this
function is called so it returns the
result of this under-under length
function and this get item is when we do
your array and the square bracket like
zero it returns the 0th element in your
array and under the hood this is the
function that's being called so when you
do this square bracket it actually did
two array that under under can item and
0 and it calls it does the behavior that
you defined in this function so let's
take a quick look at this data set so I
first initialization I give array of
images and I can give the labels of what
this image
labels are and some transforms if I want
to apply and I'll talk more about this
later and then store them as my
attributes and in my length I give the
length of all my images and this is so
that when I actually pass my data set
object into Taylor loader it needs to be
able to know what the length of the data
set is and the cat item I define to say
if it says give the 0th index the
element in the sample in the 0th index
of my data set I
to give either both the pair of X image
and why the label or if at the
initialization I said I don't want to
get my label by passing label for phones
I'll just keep the X as the image so in
the get item function I get basically if
it's a two-dimensional image I always
want to give the three-dimensional image
because that's kind of what the PI torch
modules like convolutional modules are
expecting and if I define any transforms
I apply it before I return the X image
and that's same for the X as well as for
the Y and once I define this data set I
can actually use it like this so PS
means my batch size for training and my
train yes means my training data set so
here I have a bunch of training images
that I load it before and these means
labels and and then once I define this
data set so this comes from the torch
util data and I pass in my data set as
well as the batch size that I want to
use for the training data and I want to
say every time I get this data from this
data loader I want my data to be
shuffled and this is important because
we want to be able to we don't always
want to have the same order in the data
feeding and it helps with your model
generalization by adding some noise into
your training
so I have a similar data set that's
defined in data set and it's called seg
yes and it's quite similar to the image
data set but so you can take a look if
you're more interested it but I think
here we'll just start to use it just to
move along so here I have the train IDs
which grabs the IDS of the training data
and images this train date other images
contains all the input images and train
their other segmentations contains all
the mask images this is the problem
people are having so maybe for the
interest of time it may be just better
for me to go through the whole workflow
and then I'll fix the data and you can
always ask me during the conference for
any questions so let me go through this
workflow so here ideally when the data
is there we can the data set says I
imported 1537 images and when you're
training you want you you can add some
data augmentations so when you because
your data set is fixed if you want to
add some more variations to your
training data you can either change some
colors or the rotations you can move
your image a little bit or do other type
of either cropping like center crop or
rescaling of your data to add more
variations to your data so that's what
these transform objects are doing and pi
torch
torch vision supports this transform
objects where you can compose multiple
transforms and these are color balls so
you can or class with the - - call
object so once you define it you can
actually build your custom transforms so
that's what this team pattern is doing
so I in in the tail patter I defined
pattern that adds zeros - or this
whatever value you give as your fill and
pass the data to this pet out size
because the input data are 300 by 500
and we're sometimes very you want to add
this padding so that it becomes a square
image so in this case I say Oh both
width and height I want it to be 500 so
I define these transforms and give it to
the segmentation data and then what
it'll do is it'll we apply this
transforms the before giving your x and
y so that's what this data set and data
loaders are doing and data loader is
quite simple once you have the data sets
so you you pass in your data sets and
some parameters specific to your data
loader and for the training data
I give patch size of 16 and I want to
always shuffle but for validation I
actually don't want to shuffle so the
default of your data loader is batch
size one and shuffle to be false so I
don't want to shuffle and then once I
have this data loader I can now move on
to building or choosing my model
architecture so one way to do one nice
way to visualize you
architecture is using torch summary
which gives you a nicer output of your
model architecture so that's the library
I'm using and torch vision has some
models that you can use some of them are
pre-trained and and here in model
helpers I define some functions that
helps you with further transfer learning
so freeze all so transfer learning is
when you have a pre trained model that's
for example trained on some other image
data sets like public data sets like
imagenet you want to take the pre train
model but make it more specific to the
problem you're trying to solve so in our
case we have different images like
satellite images so we need to kind of
change some of the weights and fine-tune
our model so to do that we need to
sometimes freeze all the parameters
that's what this free zone is for and
unfreeze all or just specify some other
ones that you want to Train and here I
define my model and fully convolutional
vgg sixteen based model and that becomes
my model and just to quickly see what
this model is actually about if you do
so using the torch summary library if
you do summary model and input the size
of your ideal input it actually gives
you the output shape of each layer in
your model so we see that our model has
it's based on vgg sixteen and it has
multiple convolutional blocks including
comm relu
so that's one block and Connor aloo and
then we do max pool so when we do max
pool we downsample bias factor of two so
in this case now the output becomes 250
by 250 and we do the same operation kaun
kaun max pool and now the size is
another half and then we do come come
come we have three comes and then do
down sampling and then we get another
half and then we do another conv come
come down sampling and another down
sampling up till here and then this
layer is actually where we use the fully
convolutional network how many people
are familiar with fully convolutional
network so fully convolutional net work
is so usually before it was proposed the
way it was
this kind of architecture model was
designed was we would have this
convolutional blocks that do that
extracts features from your input and
then we would have some fully connected
layers that changes all your that
flattens your last output of your
convolutional blocks and then makes it
one one D vector and then take that as
your kind of extracted feature and then
use multiple layers of fully connected
layers so that at the end if you have
ten classes you will end up with a
vector of size ten
each saying oh the probability of being
class ten is at this vector but the
problem is that because fully connected
layer expects a fixed size of
but when you design your model it's you
either need to have some layer that
changes that output of your vector to
the input of input size of your fully
connected layer but if you take a look
at it if you this fully connected
operation it's actually the same as
doing flic doing a convolutional
operation on your output of your these
common flocks but the good thing about
convolutional operation is that it's you
can do it
irregardless of the input size right
because if you have five by five five by
five output you can still do the same
combo you can still use the same
convolution layer as you would on ten by
ten because it's a convolutional
operation so that way we can we're not
bound to a specific this input size into
this kind of classifier block of your
model and so these are just a different
way to see your parameters and one thing
I really wanted to kind of talk about
was this learning rate finder method
that I find very helpful when I train my
model so learning rate is a very tricky
thing to tune and the main idea comes
from this cyclic triangle learning rate
scheduling from Leslie Smith's paper and
the main idea is that instead of taking
your learning rate as you train which is
kind of what intuitively what a lot of
people have been had tried in the past
we actually want to increase our
learning rate at the beginning of your
training and what it does is that it has
helps you kind of jump around this your
made weight landscape so that it doesn't
stock in your local minima or wherever
is close to your initialization position
so by jumping by increasing your
learning rate you're actually escaping
this not ideal not optimal local not
optimal but flat regions of your
landscape and end up with a better
better trained model so you know
different notebook 0 to see cyclic
learning rate I try to show what this
learning rate finder is about so there's
a link to the 2017 paper
so the basic idea is that you define
this triangle learning rate which is one
of the simpler version where you say how
the slope of your increase in learning
rate and decrease in your learning rate
as you train and we have this learning
rate range test where you run this you
change this learning rate in the
beginning of a couple epochs that you
can specify here the number of
iterations you want to test and it'll
plot loss as you as you test this
different learning rates at different
epochs
and when you going back to the zero zero
to a pint or data set when you run this
learning rate range test it's quite slow
because I'm using CPU at this point but
when the when the training goes we will
end up with this kind of loss graph so
you see that on the x-axis we're seeing
the number of iterations and on the why
you're seeing the loss at this different
learning rates so we see that the value
kind of decrease interestingly even
though the learning rates are increasing
and at some point the learning rate
becomes too big so the loss really jumps
so the value we want to ideally set is
some value before this huge jump so in
this case I would choose something
around each iteration seventy so this is
now kind of running the test and you see
that this using the TQ TM library we can
actually visualize this progress bar as
well let me quickly
so once I have this value say 70 the
learning rate was point zero two and
this is the value that I'm going to use
for my first round of training so and
that's the maximum learning rate so max
LR is found by this learning rate range
test and using triangle or a cyclical
learning rate policy with the model
pre-trained fully convolutional sixteen
and the loss function of cross entropy
here cross entropy because I am doing a
classification and using the patch size
of sixteen so I set the maximum value
and the minimum learning rate is how
kind of heuristic at this point but I'm
just going to divide it by three and
then set it as the starting learning
rate and I'm going to do a thirty cycle
and then it'll actually end up with 60
epochs and once I do this it'll start
training sorry
so ideally I'm not I should be using pre
trained
so once I have this model using the
pre-trained it'll start training and
then run the model
the run function will end up with this
result result which contains the loss
function lost values and some other
metrics that you want to show like a
classification accuracy and class per
class accuracies sorry for the glitch
and using this hollow views again we can
view the curve and see the Train and
validation accuracy and what I would
actually usually do is do this
evaluation on the test images and I wish
I could have covered more interesting
parts but if you see the three zero AE
full workflow for Road detection it
contains this for workflow of what you
can do using the data of the road map
route detection data set so just quickly
go over just work walk through what's in
there so similar to before we we read
the data but in this case using some
other geospatial library and then we see
that we we see the input data satellite
image and your mask data and you can
build some simple explorers like image
pair Explorer where it has this
dropdowns where you can quickly change
the data to what's in your sample data
set and you will be shown here
and this part kind of shows you how you
can extend it to bring in external data
source like OSM and use it for your
training if you want to so your
overlaying the data from OS m on top of
your own data set and moving on to the
training part you can see how you can
customize and define you transforms like
random crop and normalize and I'll try
to fix this repo so that you can see and
go through the rest of the tutorial
maybe after everything is kind of fixed
yeah thank you for your time and sorry
for the technical glitches
[Applause]